well hello they are watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages
in the next half hour then we'll see
what's making the headlines with the
observer's chief leader writer
sonia soder and the communications
advisor and former aide
boris johnson guitar harry welcome great
to see both of you
lots to talk about tonight certainly so
let's check out the front pages first of
all
queen back in the office at 95 is the
headline for the metro
following her majesty's first speech
since the death of the duke of edinburgh
plans to introduce voter id measures in
the uk
risk excluding over 2 million voters
that's the lead story for the guardian
the financial times has details of david
cameron's repeated attempts to lobby
government and whitehall officials
on behalf of the collapsed finance firm
green cell capital
the paper alleges the former prime
minister sent 56
sets of messages so the eye puts that
figure at
47. according to the telegraph the
government will publish a digital duty
of care bill
which could lead to social media firms
being
shut down if they fail to protect
children
or more papers coming in uh we'll take a
look at those when we get them sonia
soda guitar harry are here
um a paired down demonstration of what a
queen speech would normally be
like but uh what about the bills put
forward themselves guitar what did you
make of it
well i think it's pretty impressive
first of all that the queen can go back
to work you know after coving
queen can go back to work after real
terrible personal grief and at her age
and actually it was a pretty packed
program there's no
room here to accuse the government of
having run out of steam or not having
any ideas but what's what's fascinating
is the different directions in which
they
go in and the different uh types of
things that are being addressed and
that's where people are struggling to
put a sort of coherent narrative around
this other than this general idea of
getting britain back on his feet and
leveling up great to see the queen
as well um you know back back in her day
job effectively but without all the
regalia
um so soon after the death of her
husband um but let's move on to
what was in and what was out of this
many people and much of the focus is on
social care which leads to a leader in
the financial times
what's their take on this so the leader
in the financial times
is really focusing on what the prime
minister has said is going to be his
priority over the next two or three
years which is
what he calls leveling up so reducing
the regional inequalities between
areas of the country like london and the
southeast and the rest of the country
and what the ft is doing in its
editorial column is really
asking whether there's enough meat on
the bones
in terms of what was in the queen speech
and they expressed some quite serious
doubts i think they're right too
so first the first big kind of leveling
up thing is oh well we're going to be
reforming
uh planning to increase the number of
homes being built
well that's not really you know the
price of homes is not really the big
issue actually
in in sort of less affluent parts of the
country where house prices tend to be
cheaper and
planning reforms don't take us very far
there the other sort of measure in there
is around
extending loans to people to sort of
with lifelong learning so if you want to
retrain
later in your career um if there's a
sort of growing industry
you'll now be able to get a loan to do
so but actually i really don't think
that goes far enough at all i think
there need to be
bigger subsidies for people to retrain
so i think there are a lot of gaps um
when it comes to
evening out regional inequalities and
that's something that the ft has
identified in its
editorial column and i think that really
relates back to a much bigger criticism
of the leveling up agenda which is that
the government has talked about this
since 2019 in fact theresa may talked
about it long before then
but in terms of actual measures it seems
to be more rhetoric than reality
and then if you actually look at which
areas of the country have benefited
the most uh from the last decade of
spending and which have been
impacted most by spending cuts it tends
to be the less affluent areas of the
country so i think
at the moment it still feels a lot more
like rhetoric
than reality when it comes to pledges
for reducing the regional gap
yes and as as one commentator suggested
today this whole idea of leveling up
they've now got to find policy
to fit a sound bite that played well in
focus groups is that where we're at now
you've got to find something to deliver
this
i think there's more to it than that
there are personnel who need to level up
there are people in number 10 and the
policy unit boris is chief political
adviser the prime minister chief
political adviser
these are people who are from the north
of england that's not been the case with
governments or of left or right you
haven't had a whole swathe of
conservative mps
from these areas in the past with an
incentive to get re-elected so that's
going to be a big dynamic
and i think the prime minister is very
sincere about wanting to do this because
it's it's a political imperative for him
it's something that he thinks is wrong
with modern britain
you need to do it to reduce the burden
you need to find all kinds of things to
get the economy purring
but the ft you're quite right to sort of
hold the government's feet to the fire
and say this has got to be translated
now they're not really questioning
the sincerity of the aim at this point
but they are asking for flesh on the
bones and they're right to do so
at the mac cartoon uh sonia retirement
home for politicians
who used to say they were going to
reform social care
i mean in some respects we feel like
we've been here before theresa may got
our hands burnt clearly didn't she ahead
of uh
of the election she fought am i being
naive to say the reason they dodge it is
because it's just gonna
cost us the electorate and whatever
happens it won't be popular
no i think you're spot on there anna i
think we've not seen politicians brave
enough to come up with reforms for older
care for quite some time now
and it was actually you know way back in
2010 that andy burnham
uh back then proposed a fairer system to
pay for social care and the
conservatives attacked it and
and really it's become so politically
toxic since then the issue that
politicians just seem to shy away from
it
at the heart of the matter is there's
this fundamental gross
unfairness in our system this is a big
missing thing in the queen's speech
you know if you get cancer your care
costs are met by the nhs
if you get dementia the vast majority of
people
are going to have to end up paying for
very very expensive personal care that
would be covered by the nhs if you've
got cancer
from their own life savings from selling
their house
that really isn't on in fact if you take
a step back
the the arguments for the principal
behind the nhs which is free at the
point of delivery to everyone who needs
it
they apply even more to social care
because it's even more unfair and people
are less likely to sort of save
to pay for social care in their older
age during their working years and they
are even
you know to pay for their own health
care during their lifetimes so it's
it's really depressing because we've had
so many reviews and commissions on how
to pay for
older care um in the last sort of decade
or so
the vast majority of those reviews come
up you know the answer they come up with
is
we should fund care for older people in
the same way that we do the nhs it's
completely crazy
that you get your your care costs met if
you get cancer but not dementia it's
totally ageist and unfair but we just
don't seem to have the politicians who
are willing to just say
absolutely we get this like politicians
said back in the 1940s when they
were setting up the nhs you know back
then if
that if the politicians had shown the
same level of courage as these
politicians today we literally wouldn't
have an nhs maybe it's just what's nice
about that cartoon
is it reminds those politicians that
it's not that far off they may think
there's decades until they need social
care in fact for politicians in their
crime
it's going to come up it's going to
sneak up on them much sooner than they
think and they'll be in a retirement of
themselves
so it's a nice little reminder of um
this thing needs to be sorted even for
their own benefit not to mention the
rest of us yes and gito the guardian
picks up on another issue which is
proving controversial which is
this idea of having to prove your id for
voting
um suggesting that it will freeze out
over two million voters many people
suggesting
those are less likely to be conservative
voters so what's your
feeling about this yeah i i have to say
i think that's utter nonsense
you know if people are not able to vote
because they haven't got id the problem
is not that they can vote without id at
the moment but people need
an id that they can use for all kinds of
other things in life if they haven't got
an id that allows them to vote
then think of the other things they're
missing out on so instead of coming up
with some
gerrymandering kind of insinuations
which is what's essentially in that sort
of
guardian story then address the issue of
the people out there who are
dispossessed by not having the right id
or not having the right paperwork
not having the access to the right
services there's a bigger agenda there
if there's that many people who really
cannot vote
because they don't have a way of proving
who they are yeah we've got so much talk
about haven't we let's uh
just take a break and come back with all
the other subjects including they've
proven
controversial in america um that id
story would also talk about lex
greenstill too
and his evidence today ahead of david
cameron's appearance later this week
we're welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now sonia soda and
guitar harry let's just show you the sun
shall we before we
get more of your thoughts body dig at
west cafe
their front page cops began digging for
a body yesterday at a cafe
where the serial killer fred west was a
regular anded
building work so that's their focus for
the papers but let's go on now to the
financial times which is the start of
these hearings which will be a
fascinating week isn't it we're
expecting to hear from the
former prime minister david cameron on
thursday uh sonia what do you make of
the evidence we heard so far from
this mr green cell and his capital firm
so yes the sort of big story tonight
about this is first of all his evidence
i think the even biggest story actually
is some of the evidence that the
treasury select committee which is
conducting this inquiry
has put out into the public domain and
what that evidence reveals
is that cameron was actually lobbying
probably even more ministers and top
civil servants that we than we thought
and harder than we thought
so you know he was sending in the realm
of kind of like 50 he sent
in the realm of kind of 57 messages
emails whatsapp messages
to various very senior people in
government including ministers over
quite a short time span
and actually it's kind of embarrassing
for him um
more than anything else as well because
he sounds a bit desperate
in some of the messages to be honest
he's clearly pushing really hard for the
interests
of this company which he's a paid
director of having been prime minister
and i think you know for a lot of years
there's quite a lot of complications and
complexities in this story
but when you take a step back what you
need to know is that somebody who is
prime minister
has gone into a very well paid
directorship role
at a company and then they are pushing
ministers senior civil servants
making use of of these personal
relationships
to try and get changes in government
policy
for this financial services firm that
they're waiting for that they're working
for that's
that david cameron was working for he
didn't succeed in getting what he was
asking for specifically but green seal
did benefit from other government
contracts and schemes so i think this
does really expose
the fact that former ministers you know
going right to the very top david
cameron former prime minister
there just aren't enough rules governing
what they're allowed to use their
personal relationships
that they develop through working for
the british government to to achieve
for the corporate sector which is you
know yeah
taxpayers yes we're running out of time
i just want to get guitars take on this
you you know working in the
in the prime minister's office and all
of that sort of stuff the full scale the
eye tells of
david cameron's behavior at the start of
the pandemic i mean these people have
got other things on their minds haven't
they
that's kind of the point too indeed
it is embarrassing it's also in in in a
bizarre way and perhaps not in very
flattering way very very impressive some
people who
knew david cameron as a chillaxing prime
minister very prone to delegating very
effectively
very very impressed by the you know the
big shift that he put in on this one the
hard yards he actually did
a massive lobbying job i think what
people
most people and i've explained to some
people involved in some of the inquiries
in the end
they're not sure that there's a breach
of rules here they just think it's
grubby
and that it's really not on and when
you've got those contacts when you've
got that sort of standing when you've
got that authority that david cameron
had even when he
left office you could surely have put it
to better use for humankind and this
kind of law being for
you know corporate benefits and a
massive sack of gold at the end of the
rainbow for yourself
and that i think is you know what's
what's the shameful legacy for him
uh unfortunately for him yes and just
quickly guitar where might this
head do you think simply new rules award
well it's hard to tighten the rules so
you can't talk to people that you know
and all the rest of it
in the end people i've spoken to are
looking into this they say you've got to
see beyond the sort of sensationalism of
al hard you know cameron lobbied and all
that the problem only arises if there's
a genuine conflict of interest
for a person in power and the real
problem here in the end is not the
elected politicians
because there are rules that you know
kept cameron out for a couple years for
instance
but it's civil servants who had feet in
two camps people who were controlling
vast multi-million maybe billions of
uh pounds in government but also
seconded to private companies that's got
to be where the focus ends up
okay quick 30 seconds daily telegraph's
lead story about a
duty of care bill the idea that social
media giants could be
shut down if they don't look after
children properly
well quite right and i think there's an
experience here sorry yeah
sonia girl then i was just going to say
i actually think some people will be
really surprised that this is the first
time that you know massive finds are
being proposed
for big platforms like youtube that
don't even implement their own age
guidelines so i think this has been a
really really long time coming okay
brilliant
see you at birth at half-eleven thank
you both very much indeed good to harry
sonia soda thank you